we got a couple of interesting
voicemails yesterday I don't know what
led this lovely young woman to call me
and to explain that she was having
problems with her internet but check out
the first voicemail that she left me at
two one nine to david p mr. penguin
i want you to know that I'm having
trouble getting on the Guardian site the
newspaper in England
I think they slowed down the web where
you can't get a sense that I've tried
often ones throughout the day that then
I've immediately gone to other sites and
it went directly to itself
I think they officially slowed down the
internet thanks so first I thought is
she just reporting like trouble with
their internet like should she be
calling Comcast instead of me but then I
started to realize I think what she's
saying is that the inaction of the
repeal of net neutrality might already
be targeting specific media outlets and
then she called back in and said she was
having trouble accessing TYT Network I'm
Chi I'm just updating you about the
internet Baltimore Maryland
I've been trying to listen to The Young
Turks and it's a whole lot of a wheel
going around it stops and starts and
then if you refresh the page you find
out you're fifteen minutes behind so I
wanted to let you know in case you're
covering it thanks alright so listen I
have no clue what's going I have no idea
if this is because of user error or a
temporary glitch in the internet or if
whoever her provider is in Baltimore
Maryland is slowing down the Guardian or
TYT Network I really couldn't tell you
but it is interesting to hear from this
person but usually when people have
internet problems it's just user error
or just like the system is not working
properly temporarily you think the
reason for the voicemail was a feedback
on net neutrality or was it her trying
to get your take on why she couldn't
load the Guardian yeah I mean maybe if
you have any connection maybe she was
calling me for tech support that's
that's possible but I think it was a
point being made about net neutrality if
you were experiencing changes to your
internet access let me know and see if
we can get more information about what
this woman was experiencing we've got a
great bonus show for you today I'll
speak to you then